big congratulations to the 2023 US
champion Fabiano karwana yes $60,000
richer as he's in studio Christian well
Fabby first of all big congratulations
uh from the studio here you are the 2023
USS Champion how are you feeling right
now this was not an easy task from the
beginning to defend the title in fact we
don't remember last time somebody
defended the title in the open section
how are you feeling right now s it out
for us yeah overall uh it's a great
feeling uh I am very tired at the moment
and today I really didn't play a good
game but uh but the result is great I
couldn't be happier about uh about
repeating repeating the the winner from
last year tell us about today's game
because uh it was a nerve-wracking
Affair it felt like you had everything
under control under WS you were ready to
put the finishing touches and then
something went wrong at some point with
that move Queen to B4 tell us about that
move
well I think I have some sort of disease
because whenever I whenever I play with
my queen I I usually put it in a place
where it's completely trapped I did this
against Sam I've done this many times in
the past I I self-trapped my queen and I
did it again today uh Queen B4 and then
suddenly I realized like Knight C4 my
queen is it can't move it can't go to B1
uh like I I complicated my life so much
and then probably I even spoiled the
majority of the advantage at some moment
but I mean any move besides Queen before
I win the game it's just like any
anything it's uh this game should be
over in 5 minutes instead of whatever it
was like 2 hours and um yeah and how do
you how do you come back from that
because we saw your body language we
understood that you were quite
disappointed when you made the time
control at the same time you must have
known that you still have great chances
and maybe even uh concretely uh decisive
Advantage how did you recover from that
how did you put yourself back into the
mindset that you had have to finish the
job actually I was I was not too upset
after the time control I felt like he
maybe missed chances to make it even um
to get even more
compensation like after the time control
I lost a pawn but I got my coordination
so I I did feel like I had a big
Advantage but somewhere when we were
both low on time I really wasn't sure if
I had almost completely spoiled it or
not mhm and okay probably I did keep it
Advantage the entirety of the the game
but um but yeah it was very I was very
unsure because my was going to some
weird places and he was very active and
um yeah after have control I I had
already seen this A4 idea I was actually
surprised he went Queen E4 because I
thought other moves the queen is better
placed and uh yeah after A4 I thought I
have a very good chance to win anyway uh
still it wasn't because I was I think
the the position you never let go of uh
the advantage fully by any means yeah
this number is really not indicative of
what I was feeling at the moment but uh
but I'm glad to see that it was plus
three like over the board it really felt
like um of course I'm I'm pressing with
no risk but still Anything could happen
in terms of uh if I'm actually going to
win this game and only after he played
G5 I was pretty confident like this G5
felt very wrong I don't think that he's
attacking this position and yeah I felt
like there should be uh several ways to
to refute this move but Queen B6 I
thought was just a forced win like I
didn't see any chance for him after that
yeah just had to look see that after
Rook f8 basically um he yeah he can he
can take on D5 but then he can't play
Rook B5 because there's Rook
F6 it even felt like there's like a
margin other rook and and King G7 Rook
D6 it even felt like maybe there's some
other ways to win as well but okay this
this was clean enough and otherwise yeah
it's my Rooks become active uh that's
that's really the the question is not
the material in this position the
question is how active my Rooks are and
and once rooka comes they're very active
well I have to ask you Fabby everything
has been going swimmingly for you this
year you qualified for the candidates
you got once again back to that
2800 uh level it feels like you're fully
back in this one and also you defend the
national championship who do you have to
blame for this
success well I I think I have myself to
blame for some of my my uh failures in
past few years especially the candidates
last candidates was was of course a huge
failure um it was a rough period for for
some time I mean things seem to be a bit
better now I I seem to be playing better
or at least maybe the quality isn't
always there but definitely taking uh
some chances that I in tournaments when
I can and usually fighting for first
place and in most of my tournaments that
I've played and uh and also I've been
working very hard in general like not
not just in in in between tournaments
but during tournaments I've been
fighting very hard which is uh usually
better than um than the the alternative
which is like let's say some players
they lose motivation and and I was also
in that position where I was at some
point losing motivation a bit so uh
definitely it's very important to keep
uh to keep that like uh I don't know
what the word exactly for it is but uh
let's say to keep that gumption that
you're always fighting um as much as you
can tournament sometimes it doesn't work
out like I had some very disappointing
results this year as well but but in
this tournament it it did work out
pretty well guys any questions for our
champion yes indeed Fabby first of all
our congratulations absolutely backto
back Stella performance well done today
was an absolutely huge game you're
playing against MRA this 14-year-old
Phenom it's scary right whenever you
play a proy who's capable of taking down
anybody
uh I don't know if you were satisfied
your with your position at move 13 you
just played this move Queen E2 and again
you won a very smooth game thereafter
Queen E2 rook
fc8 and uh basically you kept the
advantage throughout now again just
thinking about your mindset going back
at the start of the position you're
playing against Mishra he had this
opportunity to play the move F7 F5 at
first glance maybe it wasn't something
that you feared but on the other hand
you're playing the guy who's in second
place who needs to beat you and if he
had played the move F5 did you consider
F5 seriously uh did you have an
intention if he had played which is a
pretty aggressive uh approach by
black well to be honest I didn't like my
position in general uh that's that's the
thing so basically I was already
unsatisfied on the third move because he
usually plays Knight D7 I had something
in mind there and then he plays Bishop
D7 for the first time
and you had prepared against Knight D7
not against Bishop to D7 his choice so
you were dissatisfied right here yeah I
wasn't too happy and then I remembered
okay first I remembered there was some
game uh where Richie played C4 I think
against Max cmen it was like C4 E5
Knight C3 Knight E7 and I was thinking
okay against against it maybe it's fun
to play a closed position which is very
tense and um in general I have a lot of
experience in these types of structures
so uh then he quickly played I was
hoping C4 takes him by surprise and he
quickly plays this and then I remembered
that there was some game of G of nepo
against giri and it it was like it
wasn't with Queen D4 but at some point
he played Knight D4 then he played
Knight F3 and then he played uh Queen E2
Bishop D2 and Rook B1 in some sort of
order it was like Knight C6 Knight F3
Castle Bishop D2 uh something like A6
Queen E2 Rook B8 Rook B1 and the point
is black shouldn't play B5 because um
white gets like Rook A8 Rook a B1 B5
take everything Knight E4 Queen
E4
um yeah Knight B5 Knight E4 Queen E4
Rook B5 and and White's Pawn start to
move this is sort of what I remembered
but I couldn't remember what the move
order is and then I thought why don't I
play Queen D4 and um and basically it
seems to win a tempo and then I confused
myself entirely because on the one hand
I I thought like maybe H3 is more
natural here to prepare Bishop E3 but
then I was like okay I'll play Bishop D2
after A6 I'll play Rook B1 and after
Rook B8 I was thinking okay maybe I'll
play Queen E2 and we get that game and
then he played Knight G4 I'm like what's
the point of my play I don't understand
it
um so so my thoughts were all over the
place at some point I was just like okay
just make a move I mean I I don't
understand this position clearly so yeah
I was a bit worried about F5 and if EF5
gf5 I guess is the only logical way to
kind of continue it and then then to put
the Knight on E5 and take back with the
pawn and try to get those like I mean I
didn't think I was worse but uh I
certainly wasn't happy with the result
of the opening because uh I mean clearly
he he got an interesting position and
and I got under a little bit of pressure
uh I I thought that yeah his Rook FCA
was a bizarre move I didn't understand
it um like I kind of understood it but I
thought why why is he doing this and
then Bishop C3 I also didn't understand
why he took on C3 I thought like maybe
Knight G5 is normal um like Bishop C3
bc3 I I suddenly I'm in safety I first
of all I have a drawing um mechanism if
I ever wanted you have a repetition
which we've seen yeah yeah which is nice
just psychologically and then very
quickly I saw C5 is a very dangerous
idea right because if he takes the pawn
I put Knight on B6 Rook C7 I I wasn't
sure which Rook to go to D1 but let's
say Rook fd1 he has to go to E8 with the
queen and then E5 and okay I don't know
maybe black is not uh losing here but it
it certainly looks very dangerous it it
seemed that in fact black was losing
here yeah it was a really really bad
position for black so your judgment was
spoton so I thought what he should have
done was Knight G5 after C5 I wasn't
sure how big my advantage is here after
after C5 already I mean clearly I'm I'm
better after C5 but Knight G5 and then
he takes with the
pawn and it looks very weird no no not
not CD I think Knight E5 is necessary ah
Knight takes E5 CD I don't want to play
of course and now D5 so Knight E5 would
be the game but D5 is and then he tries
to get Queen E8 Knight d8 Knight E6 and
I didn't see exactly how I continue I
mean certainly I'm I'm again very safe
position but do I have a big Advantage I
wasn't 100% sure although it does feel
like black is in danger
here well once again uh Fabby our
congratulations
Kate for our champion no just
congratulations really amazing
tournament and I like this game I know
you probably don't have great feelings
about the game but I feel like B takes
A3 and then just pushing all the pieces
away and then just having a win and
maybe missing it with that Queen B4 but
otherwise a very straightforward game
yeah very very impressive Fabby uh get
your rest still a big game tomorrow
don't don't don't let this success go to
your
head like nepo last round of the
candidates right you you know you won it
with a round to spare that are
congratulations indeed Fabby and thank
you what a penultimate round this turned
out to be a Christian oh absolutely just
uh